you probably heard clark county has  started mailing out ballots for the  upcoming election now you should  get yours by the 17th now if there's a  problem you can  call the election department you can  either mail your ballot back  or you can take it to one of the dozens  of different drop-off sites  early voting though does start one week  from tomorrow and it goes through the  end of the month to the 30th actually  you can also vote in person at more than  a hundred different locations if you  choose so on  election day and remember eight news now  is your local election headquarters you  can find updates on the presidential  election both  on air and online at 8newsnow.com